monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
olivier verrons
monsieur le ministre
l'autriche a décidé et les länder
allemande du bade-würtemberg de la saxe
et du brandebourg envisage le
confinement des non vaccinés
le concours lépine des mesures
attentatoires aux libertés publiques se
poursuit inexorablement sur notre
continent étape après étape sans qu'on
ne ne se pose jamais la question de la
marche arrière alors que notre pays
s'apprête à présider le conseil de
l'union européenne dans un peu plus d'un
mois quelle est la réaction de la france
qu'elle est aussi la réaction de l'union
européenne habituellement si prompte à
faire des commentaires sur l'état de
droit et les libertés publiques dans
notre pays plusieurs responsables
politiques et non des moindres se sont
positionnés favorablement à cette
hypothèse et vous monsieur le ministre
qu'en pensez vous l'échec malheureux de
la dernière commission mixte paritaire
sur le texte de vigilance sanitaire qui
a balayé les quelques progrès adopté par
le sénat nous met dans une situation
dans laquelle vous avez des pouvoirs
considérables jusqu'à la fin du mois de
juillet 2022 sans jamais avoir à revenir
devant le parlement monsieur le ministre
pouvez vous nous dire ici et maintenant
quelle est la position du gouvernement
position que vous devrez bien sûr être
en mesure de tenir durablement dans les
jours semaines et mois qui viennent
pour vous répondre la parole les
communes des solidarités de la santé
monsieur virant
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur et loïc hervé je
vous reconnais le mérite de la constance
puisque vous êtes prononcées
systématiquement contre l'usagé du pass
sanitaires
parmi les outils disponibles pour lutter
contre la diffusion du virus a est
toujours été contre et vous l'avait dit
et c'est votre conviction vous avez tout
à fait vous êtes fournel dire permettait
au gouvernement d'avoir également de la
constance c'est celle qui consiste à
prendre au bon moment les bonnes mesures
pour freiner la diffusion du virus et
protéger la population française
monsieur sénateurs quand je regarde les
résultats du pass sanitaire dans notre
pays les études intéressantes qui sont
publiés je me dis que vous ayez un
moment donné ou peut-être même vous
changerez d'avis et nous rejoindre et je
vous donnais une statistique
intéressante depuis la mise en place du
pass sanitaires nous n'enregistrons
quasiment plus de surcontamination dans
les bars et des restaurants vous croyez
c'est le fruit du hasard si tout un coup
au coeur de l'été les gens ont cessé de
présenter des clusters de développer des
clusters dans les bars et les
restaurants je ne crois pas c'est pas
non plus un hasard si malgré la
quatrième vague avec un variant très
contagieux nous avons pu éviter la
fermeture d'établissements recevant du
public et que nous avons pu traverser
cette quatrième vague avec peu de
dommages sanitaires et hospitaliers la
vaccination évidemment mais aussi des
outils de gestion les gestes barrière et
le pass sanitaires et qu'est ce qui se
passe monsieur le sénateur dans les pays
qui n'ont pas fait le choix du pas
salutaire vous en avez cités on va les
sites et l'autriche l'allemagne n'ont
pas fait le choix du passé ni terre
alors certes il vaccine moins 1000
vaccine mais face à une vague épidémique
qui est extrêmement violente outre-rhin
vous l'aurez noté l'allemagne bat les
records de contamination dans son pays
et le nombre de décès aux pays-bas frise
les records et là ce qu'ils ont pu
enregistrer depuis le début de la
pandémie que font-ils ils se disent
c'est trop tard c'est trop tard pour
mettre en place un dispositif type pas
salutaire et on n'a pas envie de fermer
nos établissements recevant du public
pour tout le monde donc ce qu'on va
faire c'est qu'on va dire aux personnes
qui ne sont pas vaccinés vous n'y allez
pas c'est pas le choix que nous avons
fait en france le pass and it erp permet
si nous ne sommes pas vaccinés d'avoir
un test et de pouvoir ensuite rentré
dans un établissement recevant du public
je terminerai en vous disant que la loi
en l'état ne permet pas ne permet pas le
confinement des non vaccinés et je vous
rappellerai une dernière information de
la loi que vous et pas voté mais que
vous connaissez l'état n'a pas tous les
pouvoirs monsieur le sénateur si nous
devions déclencher un état d'urgence
sanitaire au cours de la cinquième vague
nous serions contraints et nous le
ferions évidemment avec avec tout à fait
en obligeant que c'est tout à fait
normal de nous présenter devant le
parlement dans les semaines qui
suivraient dans un délai de moins d'un
mois vous savez que c'est en général
quelques jours pour vous demander votre
confiance
[Applaudissements]
monsieur hervé monsieur le ministre vous
avez répondu à une question je vous dis
que je ne vous ai pas posé après tout
pourquoi pas je veux dire on peut parler
sans cesse dupas sanitaire vous
connaissez ma position sur la sur la
question et vous êtes très satisfait de
ses effets moi beaucoup moins et je
voudrais vous rappeler quand même que la
question qui se pose en termes de
libertés publiques mots que vous n'avez
pas utilisé dans votre réponse et quand
même l'élément essentiel de réflexion se
pose sur notre continent dans des états
qui sont proches de nous et qui sont des
démocraties est là et vous n'avez pas
répondu sur la réponse de la france sur
la réponse de l'union européenne en la
matière et c'est ce que j'attendais
d'eux vous
prenez d'autres exemples monsieur le
ministre prenez l'exemple de la suède
prenez l'exemple de l'espagne qui sont
bien plus intéressants et qui eux savent
préserver les libertés publiques
[Musique]